- All right, we always
like to close out the hour
with one last, little
story to bring you joy.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
I can never say it enough people,
teachers are truly angels among us.
I want you to meet a Washington
DC elementary school teacher
who proves my point in the sweetest way.
Just before the Christmas break,
Kathleen bet her third graders,
she could make a half
court basketball shot.
And if she could,
there would be a hot
chocolate party for all.
So, as you can imagine,
most of the kids were
rooting hard for her,
probably not expecting her to make it.
Let's see if she made it. (laughs)
(children cheering)
(children screaming)
That's amazing!
(crowd claps)
She shoots, she scores.
That's so amazing!
(crowd claps)
You know all those kids were like,
"She ain't ever gon' make this."
That's so cool.
And so, the kids thought it was amazing
and they got a holiday
hot chocolate celebration.
You can tell they were excited.
We have Kathleen on the line right now,
watching on NBC4 Washington.
So, this happened on a whim, right?
- It really did.
I've been teaching at this
school for a year and a half now.
I've never done anything like that before.
I usually play basketball
with them, soccer with them.
And they know I played basketball.
They know I played basketball in college.
So, sometimes they'll ask me
to like, "Shoot this shot!"
Like, "See if you can make it."
But nothing full court, like that length.
So, I saw a ball, I picked
it up and I was like,
"You know what? If I make this,
let's have a hot chocolate
party on Monday."
It happened on a Friday.
And it went in (laughs)
and they went crazy!
- Oh my gosh!
(crowd claps)
Thank you so much Kathleen
for being an educator
and also, for just making it magical,
the whole experience magical.
And making kids want to
show up and work hard.
We love teachers like you,
especially mommas like me,
having kids that go to school.
Thank you so much for
all that you're doing.
And that was one amazing
shot girl. (laughs)
All right.
- Thank you so much!
- Absolutely! I'm liking
your post right now.
(bell dings)
And that's not all. Our
season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
The Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So, they're gonna give you $1,000
just cause you're super cool.
(crowd cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God! Thank you so much!
- [Kelly] That's a lot of
hot chocolate parties, ma'am.